a shot of Paris welcome back to CBS
mornings you are looking at pictures
from that beautiful city one of the
world's leading fashion centers you know
that industry is now facing its own
Reckoning on sex assault allegations
years after the entertainment world was
rocked by the downfall of Harvey
Weinstein and the rise of the metoo
movement Holly Williams spoke with five
former models who allege that a Top
Model agent attacked and assaulted them
in the 1980s they are now lobbying
governments to ensure greater
protections for women in the fashion
industry
I couldn't get away and he had his hands
gripped into my hips
and
when he was done he just went to sleep
and I was just laying there Crying In
1980 Jill Dot from Los Angeles was 20
years old and working as a model in
Paris France when she says she was raped
by the boss of her model agency I walked
home just in absolute like shock like
comatose just
catatonic Wendy Walsh from Toronto says
the same agent also raped her when she
was just 18. he was my boss I trusted
him because he told my mother he would
take good care of me and EJ Moran from
Chicago says he raped her the following
year when she was 22. he threw me on the
bed
he covered my face with his hand
he started calling me names he turned
into a monster in fact all of these
women are from North America all worked
as models in Europe in the 1980s and all
of them say they were either raped or
sexually assaulted by Gerald Murray a
man at the Pinnacle of the modeling
industry in Europe for decades 16 women
have now given their accounts to the
French authorities accusing him of rape
or sexual assault but because of the
statute of limitations in France which
sets a deadline for prosecuting cases
Gerald Murray cannot be charged none of
the women went to the police at the time
I thought about going to the police but
I couldn't speak French I didn't think I
had a chance I thought if I went to the
police they wouldn't believe me
Gerald Murray's long denied the
accusations against him
we are easily attacked he complained on
this French chat show in 1999 after some
of the allegations came to light in a
statement to us Gerald Murray's lawyer
said he categorically denies the
accusations and claims the women are
trying to frame him as a scapegoat for
an era that's now over this kind of
abuse is likely to happen because the
industry is largely unregulated Sarah
zif runs the model Alliance a non-profit
that advocates for models she says not
much has changed since the 80s and she
regularly gets calls from young models
who say they've been sexually assaulted
while working some too frightened to go
to the authorities where does that fear
come from you know it's normal to start
at 14 15 16 years old this is an
imbalanced power situation from the
beginning
so of course it's not surprising that
people are then scared to speak out
some of Gerald Marie's accusers are also
fighting for change they've lobbied the
French Senate to change the statute of
limitations and the European Parliament
to change working conditions for models
if you work in the fashion industry you
can be flown alone on a private jet to
somebody's Island and work in the hot
sun all day long be have alcohol used as
a weapon on you in the evening and get
raped at the end of your day where are
the guidelines where are the laws
the French lawyer who represents the 16
accusers told us there are more women
who claim to have been assaulted by
Gerald Marie but who haven't gone to the
authorities Gail
Holly Williams uh thank you for shedding
light on that story listen I think Holly
raises a good point the lawyer is too
There are 16 women that have come
forward so far chances are there's
certainly more than 16 and they
certainly need to rethink the statue of
limitations well that's just mix your
blood boil when you see things like that
exactly it's a great way to play a
harrowing stories if you're a young girl
at 20 years old you're afraid to speak
up we will follow that story for you